so today we decided to leave hunter
Street for a bit and come over to Jake's
house to shoot this piece um kind of
different from what we normally do
because it's no very sketch based very
you know skit based so we are attempting
to make a piece that is not so much
visual effects driven but more like joke
durin it's really hot out it's like 105
degrees so in this shot we're basically
in direct sunlight looking right at Luke
in order to make the shot look a little
bit cooler we're going to do is use a
reflector behind him give him some edge
light there's a reflector it goes in a
very slight edge on his face Britain
goes to by Adam coming a little bit
closer and then right now I think you're
hitting me more or less you're hitting
me too so turn towards him push the top
down a little bit yeah and that's how
you get Pro lighting when outdoors
hahaha hey let's introduce the Internet
to Luke on the behind-the-scenes hey i'm
luke barats I'm one half of barats and
bereta we make a bunch of sketch comedy
on the Internet oh yeah get this here's
the man Tosh you're welcome let me let
me walk out again
yeah what's gonna happen you may I'm a
monkey well you don't even know about
wait me you know what you do when you've
got a probably put a sec he's in your
hand on makin cow wow I'm drugged that's
all I'm Adam Lions friends with Emma
Nico and I come along and help out with
the projects every so often and the
nightmare video I sent all the quests to
go and find my wife who was poisoned by
mud crabs need to get five red walk
flowers so I can make an antidote that
is no quest mere serf good the flowers
located in Southern Highlands I've
marked a location on your map and today
I'm gonna be the really aggressive guy
who gets his car backed into Oh England
we'll see we'll see so for this week's
video we did something a little bit
different
read near who you may recognize from our
behind the scenes videos it's also
really really going to be effects and
has a YouTube channel it's called render
read
so this week he helped us with the V
effects for this piece and he's going to
show you how we do Timon okay so all of
these achievements were made entirely in
After Effects using a plug-in called
element 3d from Video Copilot and it's
actually a pretty sweet plugin that
allows you to extrude shape layers and
text into 3d objects to go ahead and
manipulate inside of your scene now it's
not as powerful or as realistic as a
dedicated 3d program but you can still
get some pretty great results also the
workflow is really fast which was a huge
bonus for Sam and Nico since they were
pressed for time
Adam hey you would better be a girl let
me tell you if there is one scratch on
my car why have you done broke out I'm
gonna break every single bone on you get
down from your face about to get mash up
okay hmm come on Aaron talk to me great
I'm gonna break every single bone in
your face come here
nobody get mashups and there's a lot
going on here in the final effect where
Luke levels up well Sam did was he made
the base plate for the shot the one with
Luke already in his full armor and doing
the jump without the swords they could
be tracked in later same thing with Luke
in normal clothes which was just shot
with the camera being still and against
a green screen once his first jump is
isolated he could be 3d tracked back
into the scene using the After Effects
cs6 3d camera tracker
after that the flashy effects are thrown
in using trapcode particular for the
particles in form for the lightning
bolts that gets swirled around a
displacement map for the shockwave and
some dust elements finish off the
explosion and once the swords were
tracked in they were actually used to
generate a melted falling particles
effect from the swords also using
trapcode particular it all adds up for a
pretty epic effect good job Sam good job
well I got there at 10:30 we talked
about the video and came up with it
pretty quick then these guys just had
all the necessary equipment like ready
to go borrowed from their
neighbors are had it like in bins in
their own apartment where they live and
we drove across town and knocked it out
in like five or six hours here I think
and yeah pretty good we just beat the
sunlight and I got to wear some body
armor so no complaints here whoo not a
bad Tuesday